though hardcore fans may have seen that
John wick movies countless times and
comb through them for references fun
facts and more the mysterious world of
everyone's favorite dog loving assassin
still holds plenty of Secrets thanks to
the incredibly detailed world of the
John wick films from John's intense
backstory as a hitman nicknamed Baba
Yaga to the hotel that caters to some of
the world's deadliest assassins many
fans might have assumed that the first
film was based on a novel and adapted
for film believe it or not John wick was
actually a completely original script in
2012 writer Derek Kolstad developed the
idea and started work on a project
originally entitled scorn about a man
who trafficked in evil and finally gets
some sort of redemption only to lose it
in the consequences another guy anymore
after a few studios showed interest he
sold it to Thunder Road pitchers because
they promised to make the movie as soon
as possible though wick was originally
written as a much older retired hitman
Kolstad revised the script once Thunder
Road purchased the rights
aided by Keanu Reeves the film might not
have been based on a comic book or video
game but the character of John wick has
made the leap to both Dynamite
Entertainment has since released a comic
book series about wicks origin story and
gamers can get into wicks mindset by
playing a VR shooter called John wick
Chronicles for the full effect though
make sure you play a few hours of
Nintendogs first from Bill and Ted to
speed Keanu Reeves has appeared and an
impressive roster of famous films in
1999 however he stepped into what was
considered to be a career-defining role
as neo in the matrix film series a
trilogy and universe that set new
standards for action films and gave pop
culture one of its best theories about
alternate realities as the techno
mystical neo the one who can control the
synthetic reality of the matrix Reeves
was cemented as a true action star which
made him an ideal star for the story of
the assassin that all the other
assassins are afraid of
my one salon I killed three men in a bar
with them soon beyond sharing a lead
actor the matrix and the John wick film
series have quite a lot in common the
two directors on the first film david
leitch and Chadds the hell ski did
stunts on the matrix and style ski was
actually Reeves a stuntman John wick
Chapter two reunited Reeves with
Laurence Fishburne who appeared as Neos
mentor Morpheus in the matrix and
diehard fans may have caught another
connection as well Randall Duke Kim who
played the key-maker and the Matrix
Reloaded showed up as a doctor in the
first John wick film Keanu Reeves had
plenty of input on the film and worked
closely with writer David Kolstad who
said Reeves was closely attuned to even
the smallest detail that could help
flesh out his otherwise mysterious
character with that in mind it's no
surprise that he turned to former crew
members from the matrix to help him
create a great action film not just for
stunts but for the directors though
Reeves initially reached out to David
Leitch and chats to hell ski to see if
the two better invite choreographers
would simply design the film's action he
hoped they would direct luckily for
Reeves they were more than happy to take
on the challenge having worked with
Reeves extensively in the past Li Chen
style ski were familiar with both his
prowess and his process making stunts
and fights on John wick that much more
seamless both Leach and still ski have
credited their work on the matrix as an
inspiration for John wick as well as a
guiding light for their overall careers
the hell ski has said that not just John
wick but most films he's worked on
wouldn't exist without the matrix and
both directors have said that watching
Lana and Lily wachowski work was a
masterclass and directing action that
still had an emotional core throughout
his career Keanu Reeves has become an
experienced stuntman in his own right
learning countless forms of fighting and
performing many of his own stunts John
wick is no exception to prepare for the
role Reeves spent months training with
veterans from SWAT teams as well as
former Navy SEALs this was largely due
to legions to hell skis insistence that
the star learned entirely new methods of
fighting for the film rather than
relying on his previous martial arts
experience
Reeves went on to do a large amount of
the stunt scene in John wick and most of
them with no double in John wick chapter
2 where the stunts and fights far
surpassed the first
filled up in the ante for Reeves as well
as for loyal viewers early footage from
John wick three shows even more
death-defying action proving that even
as he ages he's still more than capable
of stunning audiences with his stunt
work actors sidelines eNOS producers
isn't uncommon but one of the producers
responsible for John wicks arrival in
movie theaters might still come as a
surprise to most fans according to the
DVD commentary Eva Longoria best known
for her role on Desperate Housewives as
well as her various modeling contracts
is a credited producer on the first
whitfill lead since the house key both
noted that they've never met her but
they're grateful to her for writing a
check nomination
processing please hold whether you knew
it or not we have longoria to thank for
funding one of the century's best action
movies legions to hell ski obviously
drew from their experience working on
other action films but John wick also
drew its unique tone from everything
from classic action movies to four
novels the two directors cited several
direct influences on the film which
ranged from the classic Clint Eastwood
Western the good the bad and the ugly to
crime films like Point Blank and foreign
releases like the killer directed by
Hong Kong action auteur John Woo
interestingly while the film has the
feeling of a neo noir thriller the
directors have said that there wasn't a
lot of noir influence on John wick
instead they invoke directors like
Sergio Leone and Akira Kurosawa Kurosawa
in particular well-known for incredibly
influential samurai films like Seven
Samurai Yojimbo and throne of blood
comes up quite frequently when the two
discussed the first film in the series
beyond Kurosawa leach inste hell ski
have also mentioned looking the classic
action stars and directors from the
1970s and 1980s for inspiration but
their world building was influenced by
something outside a film writer Derek
Kolstad mentioned Stephen King is a huge
influence especially to show how far a
broken man will go a common theme in
Kings many horror novels even those to
hell ski and leach technically
co-directed the first John wick film the
rules of the Directors Guild of America
meant that only Stachowski could be
credited as the director while each was
instead listed among the film's
producers though the two clearly
maintained a good professional
relationship they parted ways for the
second film hence the hell ski went on
to direct John wick chapter 2 as well as
John wick chapter 3 Parabellum by
himself meanwhile leach embarked on an
incredibly lucrative career of his own
the same years to house key Helms John
wick to leach directed atomic blonde an
action thriller starring Charlize Theron
that also immediately became famous for
its incredible action set-pieces
especially its signature one take fight
and a stairwell after that leach took
the reins on Deadpool 2 the second
outing for Ryan Reynolds foul-mouthed
mercenary and fast and furious presents
Hobbes and Shaw clearly his departure
from John wick didn't hurt this stuntman
turned director
bitte and he also stays in touch with
the health ski to help with ideas in an
advisory role it's fortunate for the
John wick series that it's been able to
retain most of the creative team
throughout all of the movies especially
director chats the hell ski and writer
Derek Kolstad both of whom have been
working on Wix since the very beginning
it's clear that there's plenty of
material to mind from the John wick
universe that's the hell ski along with
plenty of audience members hopes that
the series goes on for quite some time
the house key noted that Reeves was
heavily responsible for the story behind
his character and said that he would
happily spend the rest of his career
existing within John wicks dangerous
violent world adding I enjoy making
these movies because there's no limit we
create our own mythology considering the
success to hell ski has enjoyed with the
wick franchise thus far it's certainly
understandable that he'd be content to
keep telling the seamlessly endless
story one of the many things that fans
love about the John wick series is the
careful and detailed world in which the
main character lives and kills which is
full of small details without being
obvious or cliched throughout much of
the first film audiences are actually
unaware of wicks past until other
criminals realize that one of the most
dangerous hit men alive is coming out of
retirement people keep asking if I'm
back but now yeah I'm taking on it isn't
until he returns to the Continental the
heart of this underground world to begin
seeking his revenge that the world
building truly begins in earnest in
interviews leech insta hell ski have
divulged plenty of details about the
world of the film including little ones
that fans may not have caught during a
casual viewing one such detail is that
no innocence died in the John wick
series which includes police officers
and not only our police officers spared
by the assassins they have their own
underground which works in tandem with
the criminal underground and each side
essentially leaves the other alone to do
their job you are working again now just
sorting some stuff out all in all it's
pretty sophisticated for a worldwide
crime syndicate responsible for brutal
murders yet another perfect example of
world building in the John wick series
is the use of the coins which hit man
like wick can use his currency for
everything from a hotel room to a
well stirred cocktail or discreet dead
body disposal
since these prices seem fairly
inconsistent to say the least
fans at work tirelessly to try and
figure out exactly how the gold coin
based economy actually works within the
criminal underground hey Harry you keen
on earning a coin some experts have even
weighed in to say that this is fairly
realistic when it comes to organized
crime while others have speculated that
by pricing everything at the same point
the Continental prevents assassins from
overstaying their welcome at the hotel
forcing them to use it as a simple stop
during their missions as far as the
directors are concerned their view is
that while the pricing is all over the
place it also doesn't matter because
that's not really what the coins are
about legion Stachowski have said that
they're essentially business cards that
allow point of entry as well as
indicating that the coin holder is in
the know wondering about the currency
value is ultimately missing the point
it's about the custom not about getting
change back for your closet full of
ak-47s the hotel in the film's the
Continental is shrouded in mystery there
are a few important very clear rules
including the use of gold coins and the
absolute prohibition of killing on the
grounds and the Continental
you kill them out on company grounds
Jonathan you leave me no choice but to
declare you excommunicate Oh but
naturally fans want to know a whole lot
more about how this place works
luckily the minds behind John wick
including star Keanu Reeves are working
on a new part of their world that might
explain some long-standing mysteries
about the hotel its guests and its
history in early 2018 it was announced
that stars would be developing a
television series based on the John wick
universe called the Continental which
would as the name implies focus on the
hotel Reeves is listed as an executive
producer on the project and executives
from the network told fans they
shouldn't rule out seeing him appear on
the show as well
writer Derek Kolstad will also be
working on the show alongside lead since
the hell ski lending added credibility
to a project we're already excited about
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]